What is up everybody? Welcome to Candid
Truth. We're going to talk about the
truth and we're going to get candid with
it. I'm here with my host Aubrey.
Hello. Hello. [laughter]
And we got a guest, a very special
guest. Some of you guys might know him.
I bet everyone here knows Josh from the
Founded Earth Brothers. What's up, Josh?
What's up, everybody? So good to be on
here finally live with Candid Truth.
This is awesome. Yeah, man. You had us
on your channel and it was it was so
awesome. I can't wait to get back on
there and I I just love collabing like
this. But you put out a video just like
2 days ago, a couple days ago, that just
blew my mind, man. You were like really
paying attention to stuff that was going
on with Elon Musk and Trump and all this
stuff. And just connecting some dots
with Bible prophecy, with politics, and
just kind of like where is our world
headed right now? It's it's really like
like you said a second ago, like you
heard Trump's speech and it was like he
was reading the Book of Revelation. Like
this is where we're at.
If you guys do not know Josh and the the
ministry that he has, the YouTube
ministry, it's called Founded Earth
Brothers. Him and his brother together
work on amazing videos and topics
talking about biblical cosmology and
just prophecy, things like this. And so
we're really excited for you to share
this on our channel because man, we want
to get the word out to everywhere, to
the ends of the earth. Mhm. Yeah. Yeah,
this stuff is relevant. It's prophecy. I
mean, just yesterday
we saw Congress having a hearing talking
about a threat from above.
Reminding us of Revelation, you know,
with Armageddon. They're preparing the
world, these unclean spirits like frogs.
What are they trying to get the kings to
do, the kings of the earth? To war
against God Almighty, you know? So it's
like they're trying to prepare people to
be deceived about what's out there,
what's up there. And so they're talking
about UFOs, aliens saying they found
bodies now, and that it's just it's it's
slowly ramping up. They've had those
hearings before, they've talked about
these things, and they've tried to keep
it mysterious because they know that
people are are prideful and they're
going to want to know everything. And so
if you make it mysterious, people are
going to seek and they're going to find
the information that they want us to
find, and it's usually the wrong
information. And so we've been
programmed our entire lives and a lot of
the things you guys talk about with the
the Hollywood programming and stuff. It
ties in to the scenarios unfolding right
now with Elon Musk being this Tony Stark
figure.
And I've been saying that for years that
I just have this feeling that he's going
to be this hero who's going to save us
somehow. And now he's saving the people
in North Carolina with his Starlink and
stuff. So it gets biblical and it's it's
dark at times. I don't like to talk
about people, so I usually don't do
videos like this. I feel like there's
that aspect of slandering someone and
talking bad about them. And so I do want
to clarify the things I'm saying. These
are things that that I'm seeing. It
doesn't mean it's necessarily true, but
it makes a lot of sense given what I've
learned in the past about the powers of
darkness, what they're doing, what
they've been doing throughout biblical
history. And so yeah, it's definitely a
deep rabbit hole, probably the one of
the deeper rabbit holes I've seen
in all my years of research. Yeah, I
agree. I I believe exactly like you're
saying, like
when I was growing up, I've always
believed in aliens my whole life. It
started with checking out books in the
public library at school, the school
public library, on ghosts and aliens,
paranormal, all this stuff. And I was a
believer and I was like, this is
photographs, these are cop reports, all
this stuff.
But anything that would come out in the
news about UFOs, it was always like, oh,
it it's verified, it's a a weather
balloon, it's swamp gas. They never
would say it was anything else. But now
they're on the news saying
we've we see them every day and have for
years, and we've been communicating with
non-human intelligences since the 1930s.
So you those ideas can't coexist. It
can't all be swamp gas and weather
balloons and we've been seeing them
every day for years. So there was
somewhat of a cover-up, a
misinformation, disinformation thing.
But I think what I think what they're
doing is they're trying to put the power
in the people's hands. They want over
the years they put out like uh I
remember like Fox had the alien autopsy
and all this stuff. I was like, well,
it's real, you know? It's like they're
they're putting out leaks leaks on Fox.
There's no such thing as a leaks on
mainstream controlled media. But I
thought I'm getting the secrets, you
know? And they're trying to cover it up
and we need to know. And so that's what
they're trying to do. They're trying to
bring it so that the people demand,
we're sick of you hiding the truth. We
know you don't think we can handle it,
but we can and we want to know. And
that's
that's like Satan's invitation. Mhm. You
know, Satan can't go demons can't go
anywhere that they're not invited. And
so when the people are standing up
saying, we demand, show yourselves.
Satan's going to come out on the scenes.
And like you said, they're having these
meetings and everything. It's now it's
it's official Congress meetings. This
isn't like UFO conventions anymore.
Mhm. Yeah, storm Area 51.
[laughter]
Yeah, right.
want you to do. And yeah, it's crazy how
how much they're putting out there. And
when they talk about the spiritual part
of it, somebody asked about this being
spiritual and they just kind of sweep
that under the rug. And so um I'll go
ahead. You guys want me to start on this
presentation talking about Go for it,
bro.
all this stuff. Yes. It's a it's a it's
a lot to cover, but it's important that
we look at certain aspects. And this one
here, this is just something that comes
to mind when I think about politics. And
I know we all have different backgrounds
with politics. Some of us are very
serious about it. And my dad, this is
actually something I took from him. This
is not accurate. You can't find this on
like Wikipedia. But my dad used to just
jokingly say politics could be broken
down into two parts. Poly meaning many
and ticks meaning blood-sucking
parasites. And when he said that when I
was young, it just stuck and I've
remembered it. Yeah. And it's crazy how
that saying has become. And my dad's
saying that I I mean, I don't know what
motivated him to say that. But he's
always been a truther. And so um you
look that word up and it just it's
interesting that it says here especially
the debate or conflict among
individuals. And politics is a continual
perpetuated state of conflict. And the
verse that came to mind yesterday, I was
thinking about all this and the Messiah
said, if a house be divided against
itself, that house cannot stand. Right.
And our Congress has a house system
that's literally divided by design.
That's crazy, dude.
all these seats. And it's a two-party
system. That's the Hegelian dialect.
Yes.
Hegelian dialect.
This is you know, they call it right
wing, left wing, but they're two wings
of the same bird.
That that phoenix eagle bird. And there
is an agenda. Satan has an agenda. For
any Bible-believing Christian out there,
this isn't a conspiracy theory. This is
prophecy that Satan is the god of this
world. And he's going to be the one to
bring about a one-world religion,
one-world government, all that stuff.
This isn't conspiracy theory. And so if
Satan is truly the god of this world and
he's controlling everything, then the
political leaders are just a face. They
have no power, no authority. There's
somebody higher than them. And so what
they do is they they try to give you
this illusion of freedom to make you
feel like the power's in your hands. So
for 4 years, the pendulum swings right
and the the liberals are getting ticked
off. But then voting time comes and and
we're happy because we get to put in our
vote and it always goes back left. It's
always right, left, right, left. When I
was growing up, it was Bush senior, that
was
a Republican.
Bill Bill Clinton, that was Democrat.
Then it was Bush W, that was Republican.
Then it was
uh Obama, which was Democrat. Then it
was Trump. You know, it was going back
and forth. This this is just historical
fact. And it's to prevent the people
from uprising. Because if you appease
one side, then they won't uprise. And
then okay, we need to swing back this
way. But it's a two steps forward, one
step back system where they're
implementing these laws that we've never
vote for. And then they think, oh well,
this person will will take it all back.
And maybe they might
uh maybe they might take a little back.
Which I mean by two steps forward, one
step back. They might take a little bit
back, but they've already went two steps
forward. So I hear a lot of people say I
vote Republican because I'm
anti-abortion.
Yet abortion has been has been legal our
whole life.
Nothing's ever changed, no matter who
the face of the the president is.
Wow.
Yeah, when you when you brought that
idea up to me, I was like, I never
thought about that, but that's how it's
been my whole life. And we're always
either waiting 4 years or we're excited,
you know, and it's it's a perpetual
state of being divided. I mean,
the country when early on, you know,
years ago,
1800s, Civil War era, it was north
versus south. And now it's left versus
right. And so dividing and conquering,
they've already gone one direction and
now they're going the other. Divide and
conquer, order out of chaos. Yep.
Huge strategy there. And the the thing I
want to talk about here, this is like a
a vision from the Book of Enoch. And I
know a lot of people um stand at
different places with Enoch, but I find
it fascinating um what is in this book
because it was in the Dead Sea Scrolls.
And the the powers that shouldn't be
seem to understand a lot of the aspects
when it comes to stars and what got me
looking into this stuff was Donald Trump
of course saying a star was born with
Elon.
And there's a lot to the stars and it's
demonic and it you would not think that.
You think, you know, it seems very
innocent. Our whole life, you know,
Disney was saying make a wish on a star,
all this stuff about stars.
But right here Enoch's having a vision
or a dream and what he sees, he's
explaining it and eventually that it
gets told to him what it means because
he sees one star fall from heaven.
And it says that star when it fell it
says and rose and ate and pastured among
the bullocks. Well, the star would be
the fallen angel, the chief of the
fallen.
And the bullocks would be the people.
And it says here and after that I saw
the large and the black bullocks and
behold all changed their stalls and
their pastures and cattled and began to
lament one with the other.
And again I saw in the vision
and look at the heavens and behold I saw
many stars
and they fell from heaven. Sounds like
Revelation. And were thrown from heaven
near that first star and among those
cattle and bullocks there they were with
them pasturing among them. And so in
this book, the watchers were supposed to
watch over mankind but they made a pact
and their oath sounds almost identical
to the oaths made by secret societies
today. They always bind themselves with
an oath. And the reason they all did
that back then was they had the goal of
corrupting the world and you noticed
before the flood the whole world got
corrupt. They were corrupting all flesh
and so they were carrying out their goal
and they were all doing it together so
that they wouldn't just have one of them
be punished, you know, the chief of the
fallen, that first star. They all bound
themselves and the oaths to this day for
secret societies have a binding aspect
where if you break it, there's all this
penalty of of death and just horrible
things. It's really bad and they mimic
the oath that the fallen took.
And it says and I looked at them and
behold they all let out their members
like horses and began to mount the cows
of the bullocks. And these all became
pregnant and brought forth elephants and
camels and asses. That sounds weird but
what this is talking about cuz it it
tells you what this is eventually, those
are the three races of giants that were
made, the Nephilim. There was three
races of them and in the vision they
were represented by elephants, camels
and asses. And so these unclean spirits
know that they have a punishment. It's
imminent. It's going to happen but their
time is now and they're doing all these
things they can just like they were
before the flood.
And so these three little creatures
here, where it gets interesting, we'll
look at that in just a second.
But that first star
was eventually bound. It says which had
fallen from heaven and bound it
hand and foot and cast it into an abyss.
And so you have that bound aspect and
you read about that in the New Testament
and you're like, why are there angels
bound in chains? What's going on? And so
that aspect have has everything to do
with the punishment because those
watchers did not do what they were
supposed to do and so it was in that
abyss, deep, narrow, horrible and dark.
And so you have that binding aspect.
But when you look at the political
parties, this is where it gets weird.
Remember those
races of giants were viewed as three
different creatures, elephants
camels
and donkeys. And when you look at our
political party system, it's interesting
that we have just that. And the
Prohibition Party, of course, this has
gone away but this was one of the oldest
political parties. You can look that up.
And here the stars are right there and
if you look at these like the biblical
earth model with the firmament above,
stars were placed in the firmament. And
then of course with your Democrats,
they're down there bound, of course. Oh,
that's interesting.
Yeah, and it's red at the bottom, you
know, kind of like
the underworld where they're at, where
they say they're at, you know, bound
down there. And so the stars are even
interesting. They have them just like
the Masonic stars at the very top of the
elephant's back and they and they change
these things from time to time. So you
might look up one where they're upright
and one where they're not.
Right, they are inverted now and as
somebody that uses Photoshop a lot, like
you have to go out of your way to make a
star upside down. It doesn't it doesn't
happen with
a program that you use, a digital, you
know, create even if you're using clip
art or whatever,
it's always appointed up. So anytime you
see an inverted star on some graphic
design, it was purposeful. It doesn't
just happen.
And I just wanted to clear the air or
whatever like you said, not everybody
agrees with the Book of Enoch. I
personally I I read it well, listened to
it in 2012 and I was interested and
after a lot of study
I don't really hold it as canon but
either way, we know that Satan uses
ancient writings as like a playbook. So
and and in the occult world and all that
stuff. So
whether this is, you know,
from whether this is biblical canon or
not, this is written a long time ago and
we see it playing out today because
this these occult societies are are uh
manifesting things that are written in
these ancient writings. And I do believe
that there's
truth in that anyway because
whoever wrote the book back then, they
were living in a time where they
understood biblical cosmology, they
understood things like fallen angels
gave technology to humanity and things
like that. I do believe those things and
so this is this is mind-blowing, man.
Yeah, the prophecies always try to judge
a book by its prophecy and and so far
all the prophecies I've seen in this
particular book have come true including
the heliocentric model,
things that helped me see the firmament.
So there's a lot of things that I've
taken out of it. But yeah, I understand
so many people they'll
they'll battle with me on this one book
and but it to me it's not like a
salvation issue. Like if if I was
teaching it and it was like at the very
end of the book it was like, now be
lawless, you know, like or something
like that. I'd be like, okay, stay away
from this book but And also
I I love that
I have friends that believe different
things. We can all be friends, man. We
can be in each other's channels and
share ideas.
I love debates, I love
I love sharing information. You the per-
the viewer gets to decide.
Yeah. Yeah, and and that's the thing
about being humble. The greatest in the
kingdom are humble. You can disagree
with somebody and be humble cuz we're
all where we are for a reason. The
Father may have me here to reach
somebody.
And I maybe I could only reach them
through the Book of Enoch, you know, or
he may have Mikey where he's at because
he can only reach somebody that way.
Like there's there's a purpose for
things and sometimes and we don't we
don't see it right away. So I can't get
mad at somebody for not believing
something I do and usually if you are
angry, there's a spirit attached to
something that's a lie. And so whenever
I know that from experience when I've
been wrong, if I get angry about
something for no reason, it's because
I'm wrong. Like I used to get mad about
my wife keeping the Sabbath when she
would try to like force that on me. I'm
like, why am I getting so angry, you
know? And then I found out later I was
wrong, she was right. That's true. We
see that
anytime somebody comes against
conspiracy theory or
something like that, like the Sabbath,
some kind of biblical truth,
the one who's
sharing the information is usually just
sharing scripture while the other one's
getting angry and and calling you names
or calling you a Pharisee or whatever.
And when it comes to conspiracy
theories, we're like, look, this was uh
this is
declassified
information or whatever. You know, we're
just showing evidence and the other side
they're getting angry, calling you
names, oh you tin foil hat, blah blah.
It's like you can take it or leave it on
me. I'm just showing you why I believe
it because I see evidence for it. And so
when you see that anger, you can kind of
already see who's in the wrong. This was
a party that started a long time ago?
Yeah, it says it was
a political or the Prohibition Party is
a political party in the US
known for its historic opposition to the
sale of or of alcohol pretty much cuz
they were prohibition was a big thing.
They didn't like alcohol, what it was
doing to America. And so beverages and
everything, that's why you had all the
people making their own alcohol and
everything. It almost like increased
crime when that happened.
Yeah, it's like once you make something
I think it was desired. I mean, think
about it. How do you make something
desirable? Tell people they can't have
it. Right. And it increased.
I think that was the big lure of it. It
was like, ooh, there's this gold. Now
it's golden and
oh, you can buy it again? Everybody I I
guarantee when they finally opened up
stores for selling alcohol, they were
selling out. You know, it was like Black
Friday with alcohol. Yeah. Now nobody
even knows. You drive past the liquor
store every day, you don't even care.
But if they were to say you can't have
it Yeah. it would make a frenzy.
But it was essentially the oldest
existing third party in the United
States. And so that's what I thought was
fascinating that I'd never heard of it.
I'd never seen the camel logo, you know?
Now we've got that house divided evenly,
two-party system but that was a party
um way back when.
And now we have all three of those. And
it was crazy. We were actually doing a
Bible study on Enoch when I found that
cuz a
a person told me that. We were doing the
study and I said, oh my goodness, it's
weird that they have the donkey and the
elephant and we have those political
party symbols and somebody goes, oh,
don't forget about the camel. It was the
Prohibition Party. And I'm [laughter]
like, wait, what?
Are you serious? I looked it up. I was
like, this is crazy. So that's why I
like having Bible studies. People always
bring new stuff to the table.
So you can hear what Elon's talking
about here.
You said something that caught me right
away when we were discussing
various issues just before we started.
We got the xAI data center
or supercomputer [music] center uh
training Um,
uh, installation to start of training in
19 days, [music] which is the fastest
that anyone has ever uh, gotten a
supercomputer uh, to train.
Um, And is that in that new building off
to the side? That's in Memphis,
actually.
It's in Memphis. Yeah. Oh, so so that's
where you were. Yeah. I see.
Memphis, the capital [music] of ancient
Egypt.
Right, right, right, right, right,
right.
Yeah, you're bringing what?
Perhaps that's where our new god will
come from.
Yeah, no kidding. Perhaps that's where
our new god will come from.
[laughter]
No kidding. Yeah, I wish that was funny.
Memphis, the capital of ancient Egypt.
Yeah, you're bringing what? Perhaps
that's where our new god will come from.
Mhm.
Yeah, okay. So, I want to talk to you
about alignment.
[laughter]
I wish that was funny.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, look, um, I mean, there
are there are a few things we're aiming
for with with Grok, the XAI.
Yeah. So, why did you
[laughter]
why did you pick Grok? Well, I think
Well, because of the meaning of the
word. Yeah. Um, to grok something is to
understand it at a very deep level, and
that's what we're aiming for with our
AI. The the stated goal of um, XAI is to
understand the universe. So, to really
just understand the nature of the
universe, but like, what and even what
questions to ask about the universe.
Yeah, who did you say?
Oh, let me tell you, we have a new star.
A star is born, Elon.
Yeah, he is. You know, he sent the
rocket up 2 weeks ago. Mhm. And it came
down and down and you saw all that fire
burning and
and I'm saying only Elon could do this.
It must be an Elon.
And I beheld another beast coming up out
of the earth. And he had two horns like
a lamb. And he spake as a dragon.
And he exerciseth all the power of the
first beast before him and causeth the
earth and them which dwell therein to
worship the first beast whose deadly
wound was healed.
And he doeth great wonders so that he
maketh fire come down from heaven on the
earth in the sight of men. Mhm.
And deceiveth them that dwell on the
earth by the means of those miracles
which he had power to do in the sight of
the beast.
And it came down and down [singing] and
you saw all that fire burning and
and I'm saying only Elon could do this.
It must be an Elon.
Woah, bro.
Alarms are going off when he said,
"Perhaps that's where our new god will
come from." Because out of Egypt is a
big deal. Biblically speaking, coming
out of Egypt is a huge deal. It was
where our father set people free. I
mean, just so many times. His son even
went into Egypt. People forget about
that, the Messiah. Where did he start
out? He went to Egypt and he came out,
you know, like it was coming out of
Egypt, coming out of Babylon. Right.
It's it's huge. I'm going to say Egypt,
Sodom, and Babylon are like the three
places you don't want to be associated
with. It it can be a symbolic thing just
like Revelation talks about Babylon, but
Babylon doesn't exist today. It also
talks about Israel. We're spiritual
Israel. There's neither Jew nor Greek.
We're all one in Christ Jesus. So, we
are citizens of Israel. We're not a
nation. And the wicked are citizens of
Egypt, Sodom, Babylon. So, if there's
going to be a new god coming out of
Egypt,
what does he mean by Mem- I I should
have looked into this more. Memphis is
the capital of ancient Egypt.
I didn't know that. Like, I learned
something from him because to them, this
stuff is really, really important.
Learning like, understanding how far
back this goes and it's coming from
unclean spirits. Mankind would not be
thinking of these things on their own,
but he knows this because it's
important. I believe I'm not going to
say he's just a Satan worshiper even
though he, you know, wore this soldier
of Satan costume, but it seems like to
me, just connecting the dots, that there
there are things in motion. And when you
look at Revelation and you look at not
just Revelation, there there there's
mentions of the son of perdition. And I
think people they hear the word
Antichrist and they hear about the son
of perdition and they kind of conflate
the two, which the spiritual aspect is
the same. The spirit of the Antichrist,
there were many back then. It says they
were already, you know, at work then
denying the Father and the Son. And so,
the belief systems that he's a part of,
that he helps to put in place are
against the Father and the Son. Because
he is promoting a model of creation and
using lying signs and wonders, the fire
coming down from above, all these things
to eliminate day two of creation, which
can pretty much just eliminate all of
Genesis. If you can get rid of just one
part of Genesis, the rest of it has to
not be true. It's just fictional. And
so, our whole lives we've grown up in a
world that's eliminated the very first
part of the Bible and we just would
modify our world view to mold into
mainstream science and all these things
that seem so believable cuz they have
the things of this world. Like, the
enemy offered the Messiah all the stuff
of this world. They use like, resources
are no problem to them. They will use
any amount of money,
trillions of dollars to pull these
things off, things that we can't do.
It's hard to compete with it, but the
truth can stand the test of time and
science and you can put the Father's
truth to the test and prove it. And then
you'll be like, "Well, what about all
this stuff?" Well, this is worldly
wisdom. It's foolish wisdom. The the
Bible even tells us that. And uh, 1
Corinthians chapter 3 that the wisdom of
this world is foolishness to our Father.
And so, Elon promoting that wisdom and
talking about this god coming out of
this place is it reminds me of that son
of perdition standing in the holy place
claiming to be god, you know, doing
these miracles, saying that he is god,
being blasphemous. And so, now he's
making a computer. He was talking about
this computer system. And he's even
talking about it like it's an entity.
Like, "Oh, it trained. It finished its
training in record timing." And already
given it this like, god-like ability to
do these things. And he's real big with
with AI, making this stuff um,
mainstream. Now it's taking over all of
our computers and everything. I can't
even go to Google now without an AI
answer.
But, what he was talking about
essentially was a supercomputer called
Grok. And that word Grok, when you watch
the whole conversation, is from a book
called A Stranger in a Strange Land.
Mhm.
I'd never heard of that book.
And I was like, "What What is this
thing? Let me look into that particular
book." Because if he's naming this AI
that he's saying is going to be like
where their new god's going to come
from, after that, maybe there's
something to it. And so, I looked into
it and oh my goodness, I forgot about
your little X. The uh,
you know, he just he seems to be
obsessed with this letter X and Y, you
know? But, when you take his logo Mhm.
and you mirror it, it literally makes
the Masonic compass. If you look at the
next slide. I mean, I I think that's too
close to be an accident. Look at how
Yeah.
the the the
Let's see, the whatever bar that is, I
don't know. The first diagonal bar is a
thin line, the other one is a wide line.
That makes the square and the top you
got the compass.
I just don't think that's an accident
because
all these major corporations, Google is
or Gmail is the Masonic apron. You got
the Google Chrome, which is the triple
six. You got uh, Google Play Store,
which is the Lucifer the sigil of
Lucifer.
I just don't think that Elon's exempt
from that. He's one of the richest men
on the earth and his logo just happens
to make a Masonic compass if you mirror
it. I don't think it's an accident.
Mhm. Yeah. The square and the compass.
And you notice all the people that have
that wisdom of this world, they always
have a compass in their hand. When they
get their picture, it's like, "Woah,
woah, we can't paint you. Hold on. Hold
this compass and now we're going to
paint you."
Like George Washington all over again.
They had to hold those things forever.
And there was a compass on George
Washington, the statue in um, DC. And
it's like there's like a sun in the
middle with a face, you know? It's like
their little Helios.
It's interesting. And there's the X. I
think that's another reason for it, you
know? It's that Masonic type of shape
and it's also their their deity. The
demon that spoke to Aleister Crowley was
claiming to be Horus, this ancient deity
from Egypt where, you know, of course,
Elon's talking about Memphis and I did
not know Memphis was the ancient capital
of Egypt That's crazy.
until
watching that discussion. So, what you
learn history when you get into this
stuff as well, but they all do that. I
mean, that you've seen them do that many
times. And uh, I used to think that
maybe the Egyptians just died going down
water slides, you know?
Oh, yeah.
[laughter]
So, there's something sinister there.
I wonder if he meant that the capital of
Egypt was called Memphis, not Memphis,
Tennessee. But, then it makes you
wonder, why is Tennessee
named Memphis? And why is Nashville have
the Parthenon with a 40-ft tall uh,
goddess of Who is she? Uh, I can't even
remember now, but
Um, Athena. Athena, I thought. Yeah.
You got a 40-ft golden Athena statue
right there in Nashville
where they have where the witches pride
parades or whatever, they come there and
they offer
uh, offerings to her.
That's happening right here. Tennessee,
the Bible Belt.
Yeah.
That's Yeah, they do it everywhere. I
mean, they they bring obelisks and and
stuff. I mean, it gets so dark. When I
was looking into sun god worship, the
obelisks they transport everywhere and
they set them up. I mean, things that
were in prophecy where they were told to
tear them down and they were torn down,
but then Rome found them in the rubble
and picked them back up and brought
them, you know, to America and all these
different places. Like, they if it
wasn't a big deal to them, they wouldn't
take these giant stones and ship them
over the waters and, you know, to a
different continent. Like, it's really
important to them to keep these things,
to pay tribute to their deities that
they serve. And
it is it is so dark.
Yes. Here's I'll let you talk about
this. This is So, that was me actually.
I did some research on this X.
And it says this is what I found
directly from several occult sources. I
just summarized it.
It says in Egyptian mythology the symbol
X is often associated with crossing or
the crossroads
symbolizing
a
I can't read that.
There's some stuff covering the top of
it. Can you read that part?
Which part? Sorry. Symbolizing a
Oh, symbolizing a point of transition
or the connection between different
realms. Oh, wow. Yes.
Going in the Exactly. Okay, so continue.
I can I can see it now. In the context
of Egyptian deities, X appears in the
imagery of this god Osiris whose arms
were sometimes crossed in mummification
to signify resurrection and eternal
life.
This crossing pose represents the
unification of dual forces such as life
and death
or the
the emerging of the earth and the
afterlife.
In occult symbolism X has multiple
layers of meaning. It often represents
the concept of the crossroads, a place
where different paths meet, a potent
symbol in both ritual magic and
witchcraft. In Wiccan traditions the
crossroads can signify a threshold where
energies are focused and where spells
are more effective tapping into the idea
of meeting between worlds.
Cabalistic
practices sometimes interpret the X as a
representation of
Tipheret, the balancing sphere of the
tree of life merging different energies
and acting as a point of divine
connection.
In modern esoteric and occult context
the X can denote hidden knowledge,
secrecy and mystery.
Influential figures may use a symbol to
convey alignment with these ancient
beliefs often hinting at hidden or
esoteric meanings that appeal to mystery
and power.
The X also symbolizes transformation a
concept central to many occult
philosophies suggesting
that those who use it may be
signaling alignment with these
transform- transformative, often
mystical ideals.
The
popularity of the X in modern media and
celebrity culture likely draws on this
array of symbol
symbolic meanings merging its historic
historical pagan cabalistic and occult
significance with contemporary
interpretations of power and mystery.
So, that's not the only thing I found.
We didn't get to add this in there quite
yet.
But the X is also
a symbol just like the pentagram and
hexagram to invoke certain demons.
Yeah, and then the weird they got like
planet X. We hear about that. I thought
it was interesting it talks about the
What did it say? It said um
signify resurrection and eternal life.
That is that's the ouroboros. That is
the rising phoenix out of the ashes.
This is all there's nothing normal about
it. It's all occult. It's all
gnostic ouroboros rising out of the
ashes, meeting in the other realm and
all this stuff. Secrecy. There's nothing
good about that.
Yeah.
That is yeah, that that makes so much
more sense cuz you saw the world leaders
they all got together and they crossed
their arms and like we're holding hands
and I'm like, why are these world powers
doing this? Like they're not in
elementary school doing some sort of
like PE thing. Like they're like, hey
guys, line up right there, cross arms.
Like who's coordinating this? Like the
fact that you can get these world powers
to all agree to do something that makes
no sense that's out of place. It's not
comfortable. You can barely reach like
there's something spiritual about things
like that. So, wow, that makes a lot
more sense knowing the X is all about
that crossing over aspect and I guess
that's why you see so many in in
Hollywood doing that same thing. Someone
in the chat mentioned that Memphis has a
pyramid. I I knew that Nashville did. We
were just in Nashville.
Because we actually went to go visit
that Athena statue. We're going to be
talking about that soon. And yeah,
pyramids everywhere. What's up, man?
This is America, not Egypt.
[laughter]
Black Panther movie did the same thing
and had all their fans doing that.
Really? Oh, man, I didn't know that.
Because that movie was so racially like
empowering that black people they just
want they loved it coming out just
because it was, you know, about black
power.
They didn't they dismissed all the
gnostic, all the witchcraft, all the
stuff that was involved in there. I mean
Black Panther he got his power from
visiting an animal that told him to eat
an herb which made him become a god.
It's exactly the Garden of Eden. It is.
I didn't know that. Yeah, and then he
drinks from this
purple potion that sends him into like
this other plane of existence where he's
talking to spirits of the dead, his dead
ancestors. It's all about ancestor
worship, witchcraft and gnosticism.
Yeah, necromancy. And yet everybody not
everybody but a lot of people
just discarded that because
it's it's a movie for black people. And
that's how that's how Satan traps you.
He's he wraps up his message in a story
that touches your heartstrings.
Yeah. And he's they seem to really the
the
the unclean spirits really seem to be
targeting black people for some reason.
It's like they really have a dislike for
them.
And just try to like target them. You
know, like give them all these different
cultures and norms and and things in
media. Like they're really being
targeted heavily. Of course it bleeds
over into every other
um culture but it's like, man, it seems
this extra effort goes into that. It is
true.
Interesting. I didn't know that about
the Black Panther.
All right. So, this book is based on
what? This is Stranger in a Strange
Land. It's the one that Elon was talking
about that he's naming this new AI
supercomputer after. Grok came from this
book that he loved. And so, when I
looked into this book I thought, well,
let me just look into that. It can't be
that weird. And then I saw the guy on
the cover has this X. That's crazy,
dude.
And he looks like a bound angel. Like
you remember he's in this abyss. That's
where those angels were bound. And then
there's just like upside down mermaid
figure. I don't even know what this is.
But I just pulled up the book and it
brings you to Amazon. And there was a
couple different options for the cover
of this book. Wow, dude.
This one looks like the Messiah. They
got, you know, pretty much Adam and Eve
figures right here with the serpent.
Some little golden grail here and this
guy
trying to mimic the pose of the Messiah
it it appears to me when I look at him.
That's what I see. Well, yeah, his feet
are crossed over. He's got his arms out.
This is definitely He's wearing all
white, a white robe. This is the most
famous science fiction novel ever
written. Are those bones or rocks in
those big
It looks like money.
Okay. Looks like big stacks of cash but
I could be wrong. I think I see like
little dollar bills here and then
basically probably Babylon and the
modern day Babylon in the background,
the purple
scarlet, you know, the curtains back
there and the purple curtains going on.
crazy, dude.
This is a weird looking cover and it
like the two don't seem related but
somehow they are. And I'm guessing
that's the Martian guy, the guy that
came from Mars.
And that art that author he has written
tons of books and one of them was the
number of the beast. That's crazy.
the author that Elon likes wrote a book
called The Number of the Beast and
here's two different options for his
cover as well. This is literally you can
say, well, maybe it wasn't biblical but
there's a six, a six and a six on the
head of a literal beast here. And then
this planet here, this red planet has a
six, a six and a six built into the
crater. Straight up, dude. And so, it's
it's right there. And and that's the
author
that wrote the book that he is now
naming his new super AI after, you know,
that he's going to infiltrate with
everything, you know, it's given this
power
um to do all these different things cuz
it's they're going to make it godlike.
They're always trying to make what man
creates better than what the most high
creates and they can't. These things
can't reproduce. They can't heal
themselves. They can't do the things
that our father made us to do. We have
the breath of life. And so, they're just
trying to mimic. But when I I was
started looking into the book cuz it
pulls up a little a few paragraphs, a
sample of what's in there.
And it talks about this character, this
Martian guy being intelligent an
intelligent creature with ancestry of
man but he is more Martian than man. So,
in other words, he's mixed with
something else. Well, we know that
aliens or Martians are demons. So, this
guy's half demon, half man and he's more
demon than man.
Yeah.
[laughter]
Yeah, and he's brought up by a race
which has nothing in common with us.
There's that aspect. And then I saw a
name here that stood out, Captain Van
Trump.
And it reminded me of
a book that I'd came across that was
probably one of the most deep rabbit
holes ever of
like I mean it was crazy cuz somebody
shared some pictures of this on Facebook
and I was like, let me just fact check
this cuz this can't be true.
And sure enough in the Library of
Congress this book was there.
Baron Trump's marvelous underground
journey. And Baron Trump was a time
traveler. And when you look at the full
name of this character it's William
Baron Trump or Wilhelm Baron Trump.
Baron Trump's name is Baron William
Trump. That's crazy, dude.
this is like so crazy. And I I looked up
um the full name of the guy in that book
that we were just talking about,
Stranger in a Strange Land, and the
captain's name is William Van Trump. So,
you've got that Van, kind of like Van's
and Trump. William Van Trump.
He was a man of humanity, you know, all
these different things they say about
him. What book was this in?
The the the uh quote at the top of the
screen is from Stranger in a Strange
Land. That's the name of the guy, Van
Trump is William William Wilhelm or
William Van Trump, very similar to
William Baron Trump. Yeah, the Baron
Trump, what is that from?
That's from uh Baron Trump's Marvelous
Underground Journey. It's from the
1800s. Okay.
uh or late 1800s, I believe. And then
where it got really weird, though, was
looking at that, looking how similar he
looked to Mr. uh Baron Trump here.
Even the dog, the family dog looks the
same. It's kind of weird. Oh, that is
really weird. What? Yeah, let me look at
the dog. It's the same face. Like they
the time-traveling dog. Dude, [laughter]
no way. Wishbone. Is that the story of
it?
Yeah.
They were All this stuff is
interconnected, but there's his little
demon figure right here. It's got to be
a Nephilim. Look at that. But um
image This is from uh that book, same
picture I showed you earlier. But what
happened was there was another book that
came after this called The Last
President. No way. And there was people
being told to keep inside their houses,
you know, quarantines. And I was finding
this out around the time, you know, when
they had the pandemics and all of that.
So, I was like, "Oh my goodness." This
was like right before the election when
I was starting to see all this. And I
was going, "Donald Trump's going to be
the president. He's going to be the last
president." And then Biden won, and I
was like, "Man, this book's stupid."
[laughter]
It didn't come true. And now here we are
on the verge of a a Trump presidency yet
again. And it was it was a madness in
this book whenever this president gets
elected, this last president, um there's
that Trump aspect.
He off He also has somebody in his
cabinet with the last name Pence.
And his hotel was on the Fifth Avenue in
New York.
And it says right here it's the quote
from the book, "The Fifth Avenue Hotel
will be the first to feel the fury of
the mob." And so, they had to send
troops in and all this stuff. And would
they be there in time to save it? But
that's where Trump Tower is, Fifth
Avenue in New York. Dude, no way. And
this was written in 1900
or what? Around that time. That's like
19 That's That was actually what the
book was called, 1900, The Last
President. It may have been written in
um 1898 or something. Yeah, so I'm
trying to think of when it was written.
I can't remember. But they had a lot of
things, and their election was November
3rd. I guess that's kind of a common
time. Um sometimes it's not that day,
but usually it's on a November 3rd. And
I think this time was a Tuesday as well,
the voting.
When we had our election Tuesday, it was
it November 3rd? Was that what it was
this year? I think it's the 4th. It My I
was born on November 3rd, and I think
election day is always the 4th or the
5th, something like that. Okay. So, it
was it still on a Tuesday this year, I
think. Cuz it was reminding my wife and
I of that Lego movie, remember President
Business, Taco Tuesday, trying to end
the world. Lord Business. [laughter]
Lord Yeah.
Yeah. So, we were like, "Oh my
goodness." You know, we That movie
actually helped us wake up because the
guy that little Emmet, he's like he's
talking, and he's like, "But he's such a
good guy. He makes uh uh and the the
place where he uh what was it? Uh
I'm trying to think of the name of the
business that pretty much runs
everything. Oh, yeah. Corporation. He's
like, "They make all history books,
voting machines." And then he's like,
"Wait a minute."
He's kind of has like that moment of
like clarity of like, "Wait, they make
everything."
all that in it. I know it's it's
completely gnostic, though, cuz it's
it's all about um
the whole Lego world, everything's
awesome. Everything's awesome because we
all live by the instruction books.
But then you see the girl Lucy, which in
Gnosticism it's this female uh Lilith.
No, is it Lilith? No, it's I can't
remember her name now, but Yeah. Um she
represents the serpent in the garden
who's waking Adam and Eve up from this
tyrannical villain of a god who put them
in this perfect world. But yeah, her
name is Lucy, like Lucifer, and she's
the one that's waking Emmet up and
saying, "No, you have to like literally
tear up the floors and all that kind of
stuff."
And when Yeah, when he comes face to
face with his father who's Lord
Business,
the dad looks around and and sees all
the rules and stuff, and and he ends up
just, you know, tearing it all apart
with his kid and putting the
Legos together in all different ways and
stuff. And so, again, Satan loves to
wrap up things in a different package,
like it's it's all about creativity. But
why is the bad guy named Lucy?
Builders are Masons. Masons are a type
of a builder, you know.
Wow. That's right. So, you're a master
Mason, you're a master builder. And
somebody in the comments, and I always I
always read comments, and I and somebody
said, "You know, it's interesting that,
you know, Yeshua was talked to as the
stone that the builders rejected,
right?" Mhm. What kind of builders work
with stones?
Masons, right? Masons. Yeah. Isn't that
interesting? That's crazy, dude. That's
like
the stone that the builders rejected.
And they said, "You do know that this
builders using stones are Masons." And
I'm like, "Oh, no."
There's a connection.
Now I can't unsee that. Yeah, that was
So,
definitely interesting with that book
and all those connections. And so, it's
more of like a
conspiracy rabbit trail, but still I
feel like the demons want to put their
information out there cuz they know the
plan, they know what they're trying to
do. And they're going to put it out
there in books for years. They're so
excited, they can't wait. Kind of like
when you want to tell somebody a secret,
like you got them a present, you almost
want to just tell them. Like they want
to tell their part and put it out there
as much as they can. Well, I
I just heard a quote. I can't even
remember where I saw it now, but it
said,
"Symbols are
uh to keep things secret for those who
don't have eyes to see, but they're to
reveal to those who do have eyes to
see." So, if you're a Mason, and you
know all this symbology, and you see,
"Oh,
uh Gmail. Yep, that's that's my boy
right there. That's that apron. Oh,
Google Play Store. Yep, uh Luc-
Lucifer's sigil. You know, they're
seeing this stuff. They know, like,
"Okay, that's
that's one of my buddies because they're
using the Masonic logo."
But it's right So,
what I'm saying is they they put this
stuff in your face because they're
they're they're telling their prophecy,
their side of the prophecy. It's like
predictive programming. It's
telling you what's going to happen
almost to where you're accepting it
because, like I said, demons don't have
any
any authority to come into your life
unless you invite them in. If we're
sitting around and we're watching movies
that literally make God the villain,
make Satan the hero, and has a prophecy
about
fighting against God and all these
things, and we're entertaining ourselves
with that, and we're getting enjoyment
out of it, then we're we're allowing
Satan into our lives.
And so, that's why they do that. They're
they're wanting to put their message out
to the world in a way that makes us love
it.
And they're telling their prophetic
view.
It's crazy, man. Yeah, that was my
favorite childhood memories.
Yeah, superheroes, you know, Superman,
like Kal-El, light god. You know, I did
not know that it meant light god in
Hebrew.
And it's creepy. Now that I think about
how much
He fought against Lex Luthor, the law.
Yeah. Wow.
So, this this was a recent tweet by Elon
Musk. Uh
you know, him and Trump are just like
good buds now, but why would you post a
picture of this with your kid, "Me and
Trump, my my buddy," and put Novus Ordo
Seclorum?
Right there, dude. I mean, that is
that's Latin for New World Order.
The the new order of the secular
seclorum means worldly.
And uh it's right, you know, the same
slogan that we see on the dollar bill.
Why did he put that there?
He's literally telling everybody, like,
"Now that Trump's in, we're going to
have a new world order."
[laughter]
People are buying it. It's sad. Like I I
hate it cuz I like I I like I patriotism
was such a big thing when I was growing
up, and it's hard realizing
it's not it's I mean, it's People don't
just want to give up and lie down. It's
like, "We're going to just give this
country up and let them win." You know,
but
our father was the king, and Israel
wanted a king. They wanted a king of
their own, just like the surrounding
nations. And we have doomed ourselves to
this type of system that we have. People
act like the laws a burden, but I'm
losing 31% of my paycheck every month to
taxes. Right.
10% would be a dream. If you said, "Hey,
we're going to have this system where we
we're only going to take 10%, and that's
it. You can buy your food tax-free. You
can grow it out of the ground, it's
free. You don't have to pay taxes on
your land." Like there's a really good
system. You acquire wealth, that's okay.
You know, it's like all this stuff was
set up to to bless people. And now it's
like we've got them taking our money,
which the prophet Samuel, he told us
what would happen.
He said, "This is going to happen.
They're going to take this, they're
going to take that." And here we are.
Now Elon's getting, you know, he's going
to help with budgeting and spending.
Meanwhile, his company that we're paying
is getting billions of dollars. They're
spending more on space travel now than
they ever have. How is that efficient,
you know? Yeah.
About That's right there. Cut some of
that out.
Did you vote on that? Did you vote to do
that?
Um
to do Did I vote? Yeah, did did you vote
to Did Did that's where you wanted your
tax dollars to go?
No. I It's like we can't
either.
Mhm. Weird.
Strange times.
And then um there was that Trump Tower
thing. I just wanted to prove to people
we're not making this stuff up that
Trump Tower is 5th Avenue. Really on 5th
Ave? Just like the book.
Just like the book. Now we're going to
talk about the good book and there's a
book of the law that you read about when
you're reading the Bible. This is where
it gets biblical
and where it really hits home because
you think of the words that our Messiah
talks about when he returns
and hopefully you can remember those
words cuz he told his disciples, this is
what, you know, basically when he
returns what he's going to say. And it's
it's words and those words depart from
me are followed by a certain phrase.
Right.
And we'll get into that, but I want you
guys to be thinking about that. If you
don't know it, you might want to look
into it cuz that's not Old Testament
stuff. That's not New Testament. That is
future quotes. It's what he's going to
say when he returns and we read about a
book of the law
with Deuteronomy here
and it says this, if thou shall hearken
unto the voice of the Lord thy God to
keep his commandments and his statutes
which are written in this book of the
law. Mhm. And so it's talking about that
book of the law. You see that word a
lot. When you look it up, just type in
Book of the Law. It'll pop up in Bible
Gateway over and over and over and I
thought, what is this book? You know,
like it's not [clears throat]
Exodus, Leviticus, Numbers, Deuteronomy.
It sounds like it's its own book, you
know? Right.
So I started looking into it. I was
trying to find it. The first thing the
internet pulls up, the absolute first
book,
the Book of the Law, was the Satanic
Version. Oh my goodness.
Aleister Crowley's book from 1904.
It was called The Book of the Law. Yeah.
And this was his Satanic scripture
dictated to him by demons. Mhm.
And this Book of the Law serves as the
foundation. This thing actually impacted
society, culture, that do as thou wilt,
that whole free love hippie movement and
all that stuff in the music industry was
all impacted by the writings from this
guy. They were all It was a a shift and
he called it the Eon of Horus and look
at the Egyptian deity above the globe
for
Mhm.
SpaceX and their stuff. It's all
mimicking this religion. The logo in the
middle is their Thelema religion, the
Satanic religion. And you see those
types of marks in everything in space
travel, um Star Trek I think had the big
logo just very similar to that. And
you'll see why.
that that um pharaoh-looking thing was
like looking gazing right up at a star.
Um and I'm just thinking of, you know,
Lucifer, son of the morning and
all that kind of stuff, you know, we
know that stars are symbolic for angels.
We know that Lucifer is a fallen angel.
And it
maybe I'm reaching, but that's just what
I see. Yeah, now it gets deep. The stars
is what I want people to think about cuz
it's
it's important to them and the demons.
They wanted There was an agenda with the
stars and so whenever Trump said a star
was born and he's talking about Elon,
that's what caught my attention because
that book, that Book of the Law, and I
don't like reading from it. I don't like
mentioning some of the things they say.
They're very crafty. You have to realize
you're dealing with dark powers that
have been leading the Father's people
astray. People that watched the Red Sea
part. They can lead those people astray.
Humble yourself and know that you can be
led astray. You have to stay away from
this stuff. But I want you to see just a
snapshot into [snorts]
what they're saying cuz they push this
in rap culture. You'll see rappers that
say
which slogans do as thou wilt. I didn't
even know what that meant.
But essentially it's lawlessness and
those demons, that's what they want to
push and you'll hear their wording. It
sounds good to your flesh because your
flesh wants to give in to temptation.
And so they they're they're praying on
that. And it says here, do what thou
wilt shall be the whole of the law. I am
the snake that giveth knowledge and
delight and bright glory and stir the
hearts of men with drunkenness to
worship me. Take wine and strange drugs.
They want you in a state of Yeah.
not being sober, just drunkenness.
Whereof I will tell my prophet and be
drunk thereof.
Lust and enjoy all things
of sense and rapture. Fear not that any
God shall deny thee for this. So they're
saying, don't worry about other gods.
Nobody's going to do anything to you.
Just be lawless. Well, guess what?
When those demons were
facing the Messiah face to face, they
didn't sound so bold and cocky.
They were terrified. And you see this
right here in Matthew chapter 8. It
says, when he came to to the other side
into the country of Gergesenes or
Gergasenes or however you say that,
there met him two possessed with devils.
That's those unclean spirits. Same ones
same types of ones talking to Aleister
Crowley coming out of tombs exceeding
fierce so that no man might pass by that
way. And behold, they cried out saying,
what have we to do with thee, Jesus,
thou son of God? Art thou come hither to
torment us before our time? Mhm. They
know they have a time. Yeah. Their clock
is ticking. And so when you go back to
their prideful language, it's like, oh,
don't worry about any God, you know,
punishing you for this stuff or denying
you. Yeah. What you're saying about
What you're saying about this do what
thou wilt, it was Jay-Z had had that
directly written on his
chest, but it it comes in many forms.
When Disney says it, it's
follow your heart.
You know, but the Bible says the heart
is deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked. Who can know it? So
yeah, he wraps it up in these fluffy
things like you got songs that are like
do what you want to do and listen to
your heart and all this stuff. Yes.
and over and over from Disney to every
pop song to every movie in some form or
fashion is saying do what you want. Even
back as far as Frank Sinatra, he he had
that I did it my way and so many people
remade that song and it's like one of
the most Satanic [snorts] songs that was
recognized like the oldest most Satanic
song.
Yeah, it it is and it comes back to this
particular
um type of mindset all the way back to
ancient Egypt and beyond before that,
before the flood. And that X symbol, you
know, with Horus, that deity that has
the arms in the X shape.
This is the words that allegedly he
spoke in that book, that Book of the
Law.
And it's sad. It's it's sad, but we know
it's not true. We know that he's a liar.
And he says here, with my hawk's head, I
peck out the eyes of Jesus as he hung
upon the cross. I flap my wings in the
face of Muhammad. There you go. Get the
Muslims. Let them realize they're in
this battle, too. Of Muhammad and blind
him. With my claws I tear out the flesh
of the Indian and the Buddhist. Doesn't
sound racist at all. You know, it's all
about They're the They're the accepting
side. Meanwhile, they're talking about
killing a Jewish man, you know, poking
his eyes out, doing all these different
things.
Um and they say I I spit on your
crapulous creeds. They're the one that
helped write the creeds. Wow. Um and so
they they have all these different
things. I don't want to read all of it,
but right at the very end it says, but
the keen and the proud, the royal and
the lofty, ye are brothers. So they want
them to feel like they are royal and
lofty and brothers. Mhm.
As brothers, fight ye. Remember that
slogan? Fight. Remember? Right.
Here is no law beyond do as thou wilt.
And look at Aleister Crowley on the
right. He's mimicking their symbol from
the days of old.
Yeah.
frost mark right there, the X that
Aubrey was talking about. It's important
to them for a reason, that crossing
over, getting people to mess with that,
invite them powers in. And this book,
the reception of this book, Crowley
proclaimed to be the arrival of a new
stage in the spiritual evolution of
humanity. And he referred to it as the
Eon of Horus. With that, of course, do
as thou wilt being the whole of the law.
And that's what you're seeing being
pushed. And look at how they write that.
The A and the E connected there. That'll
come up into play in a minute. Do you
remember a long time ago there was a
cartoon on MTV called Eon Flux.
They made a movie about it, too, but
that was the same spelling right there.
Really? I didn't even catch that. That
was a dark cartoon. I remember that cuz
there were certain channels we weren't
allowed to watch after certain hours and
that was one that would come on at night
and
of course, when you're told not to do
something, kind of like the prohibition,
don't do it, you're like, let me see
what's what I'm missing out on here.
So yeah, that's very crafty the way they
work and and right here, this is an
important one for people to know
when they're investigating reality
of what we live on because this is what
the demons were saying back then. They
said, you shall know that the chosen
priest and apostle, those those words
sound familiar cuz you hear them in the
Bible, they have their version of
infinite space is the prince, priest,
the beast and in his woman called the
scarlet woman is all power given. They
shall gather and now he's going to try
to sound like the most high. They shall
gather my children into their fold. They
shall bring the glory of the stars into
the hearts of men. Wow, dude. I am
infinite space and the infinite stars.
So he's deceiving his own people telling
them, I'm infinite space. I'm infinite
stars. And what do you see these people
promoted by the world saying? Billions
and billions and light years and
infinite and on and on and on. They're
pushing these demonic lies. These lies
of infinite space come from demons. And
they want you to glory in the stars. And
what I find interesting is not just the
Masonic stars, you know, the Hollywood
star, you want to be a superstar, a rock
star, Star Wars, Star Trek. So many
times we grew up with the stars. And
even the Star Trek logo, I was looking
at it. It's like an upside down cross
with like goat horns in the middle of
it. Yeah. I know.
Being a rock star, wishing upon a star,
and Disney, and I was thinking about
their little logo song as you guys we
were getting set up to go. And it's when
you wish upon a star makes no difference
who you are. Anything your heart desires
Oh, there it comes to you.
If your heart is in your dream, no
request is too extreme.
When you wish upon a star as dreamers
do.
Isn't that dark? It's always the dark
Yeah.
That's how you manifest
of their secret longing. Oh my goodness,
this gets darker as I'm reading.
I didn't even read the I didn't read
this part earlier.
[snorts]
Fate is kind. See, it's very It sounds
like a demon wrote this. She brings to
those who love the sweet fulfillment of
their secret longing like a bolt out of
the blue and that fallen angel there.
Fate steps in and sees you through. When
you wish upon a star, your dreams come
true.
A A A signed off by Aleister Crowley's
demon who now works for Disney. I mean,
that is just
bow at to Satan, he will give you all
the kingdoms of the world, right? Yeah.
And he will. And And the stars where
where the truth is with the stars, you
take away their lies of infinite space.
Day four of creation is when the stars
were actually made. And he made the
stars.
And I want to read this cuz this ties
into the whole the glory of stars. We're
going to look at what they really are.
It says, "Let there be lights in the
firmament of the heaven to divide the
day from the night, and let them be for
signs and for seasons, which is
appointed times, and for days and years,
and let them be for lights in the
firmament of the heaven to give light
upon the earth, and it was so." And what
did he do with those lights? It says he
made two great lights. The greater light
to rule the day and the lesser light to
rule the night. He made the stars also.
So, the stars are separate from the
greater light and the lesser light.
They're not the same. You have the
greater light, the sun, the moon, and
the stars. So, three types of lights
right there being made. And he sets them
in the firmament.
That's the biggest deal right there.
They're there for a reason. They were
set there by our father. And guess what?
Now they're in infinite space like the
demon said. There's no firmament.
There's no expanse. They're infinite
space. Yeah. What does NASA tell us?
That our sun isn't even the great light
that our father tells us it is. It's
just a medium-sized star. Wow.
That's what we're That's what we're
looking at above us. A medium-sized
star. And we're not in the center. It is
now in the center. And we're we're going
around it at half a million miles per
hour. And so, they want us to glory in
stars so much that even the main light
that we see every single day is a star
in our imaginations growing up. That is
how far they will go to twist the truth
of creation, and it's heartbreaking
seeing that people like me who knew the
creator, had miracles happen, believed
the demonic version of reality. So,
there's just so much to it. I mean,
we're bringing stars into our house.
Every single a um company or a What do
you want to call it? Organization whose
name literally is the Hebrew word for to
deceive, to beguile, to lead astray. Nas
Na- Nasa in Hebrew. Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, it's
it's heartbreaking, but it's a it's a
it's a wake-up call I think people need
is to see where their beliefs and why
they've seen so many things over and
over at the you know, the start of that
Disney movie. They always play that
music, when you wish upon a star music.
It's demonic, you know? Yeah.
It's the opening of everyone. And I
watched them growing up, you know, we
had a big case of Disney movies. Our mom
wanted us to have a good childhood, and
she thought, you know, if you have all
the Disney movies, you have a good
childhood. And we did have a good
childhood, but
um you know, anytime you could find a
VHS at a yard sale, we'd get them, and
we had almost every single Disney
cartoon. And
we watched almost every single one of
them. I had no clue I was being
brainwashed subliminally by all that
stuff. But fortunately, being called out
of Egypt, out of Babylon.
And then
of course, here looking at like we
talked about the enemy having a version
of their thing of the father's truth.
They like to have um things that mimic
that. And I feel like this could be one
of those things. I could be wrong, but
this has to do and I I don't like
talking about somebody's children, but
Elon has 12 children a lot like Jacob in
the Bible. And
Jacob had six children with his first
wife or with I guess Leah. And here this
guy is having six children with his
first. Of course, the his first child
passed away sadly.
And um then he had twins and triplets
with this lady.
And so, six children, one lady.
And their names I think Mikey, you're
going to get into the meanings of the
names. You've done some more digging
than what I did. But one of them, X, and
I said, "Remember that AE and the Eon of
Horus, what it looks like?" That's what
the AE looks like in the name here. And
they tried to put numbers in his name.
Sounds very revelational. But tried to
put numbers in this child's name, and
they said, "No, that's illegal. So, you
have to use the Roman numeral two."
of his name, that's crazy. Yeah. So,
they're like, "We're not going to let
you do that. It's illegal in
California." You figure California would
be like, "Sure, just as long as it's
purple six."
Are you misgendering me? Are you like,
come on. I'm I'm whatever I want to be.
I can be numbers. I can be a symbol like
Prince.
Yeah.
So, this their name meanings I mean, it
just it's something you wouldn't want to
name your child
um a bunch of numbers and letters and
and things like that. But they nicknamed
this person Dark Star.
And then um
the nickname One of his kids is actually
named Dark Siderael. Xa Dark Siderael.
And so, their nickname is Y or Y. So,
just a letter again.
And then um just weird names. Just so
many weird things. The 12th child
had their name
that one's name, the the one with the
weird symbols and stuff. Is they
nicknamed that Is it a boy or a girl?
I think boy. I could be wrong. I just
Yeah, who knows anymore. I don't know. I
don't know. I was I was assuming 12
[clears throat] 12 boys, but I could be
wrong. The videos are very hard to find.
Star.
If If a star is a angel, you're talking
about a dark angel. Dark Star.
one that's literally called Xa Dark
Siderael. Like, what's up with the dark
names, man? Mhm.
Dark darkness. I I mean, it's just it's
Pray for those children cuz I mean,
they're born into this. I know. Pray for
I guess pray for Elon too that hopefully
he can have a change of heart. Not
fulfill his purpose, and the enemy can
always find somebody else. You know,
there's always somebody on
on backup.
And then there's your what you were
finding on I hear about this, some of
the things you guys were saying.
Nevada, I I just looked up every name,
but Nevada actually means snow cap or
snowy, which I'm thinking of, you know,
that wall that ice wall that's holding
everything in.
Yeah. So, this may or that may or may
not be a stretch, but it seems like
all the names of his kids kind of go
together to tell some kind of message or
something. Yeah.
like the snow snow-capped or snowy. And
then Xavier, again, you got these X's
everywhere. Remember X-Men, the guy that
the leader of X-Men, his name was
Xavier. Oh, yeah. That's one letter away
from being savior. X Oh, wow, dude.
Yeah, and it means new house or castle.
So, I don't
I don't exactly know what that means,
but it's talking about some Jesuit.
Yeah.
Oh, it is.
came from. Where a Jesuit missionary
found St. Francis Xavier was born. So,
he may be referencing it to this Jesuit
guy.
And then the next name
Um so, the person's So, Xavier got
turned into Vivian. So, one of his kids
is trans, which means alive or lively.
But down at the bottom it says that a
king A C who gave King Arthur
his sword Excalibur. So, again, you got
another X. It's like everything points
back to X. Xavier, Excalibur.
Um Griffin is a winged lion-bodied
creature.
And And it also means lord or prince.
So,
That's in Revelation. Yeah, and when you
look in the Bible in Daniel the lion
with eagle's wings represented Babylon.
Mhm. Mhm. So, he named his child a beast
that is in reference to Babylon.
Wow.
That is creepy.
So, this is why I mean like a story
because Kai means sea.
And where did that lion with eagle's
wings come out of?
Oh, man. The sea. Out of the sea. This
could also be, you know, talking about
the waters above the firmament or
something too.
Yeah.
That is dark. Um
So, one of the kids' names is What is it
again? Saxon. Saxon. And it says, you
know, the Bible does not provide much
information about the Anglo-Saxons, but
some have interpreted in different ways
the end of Anglo-Saxon age and the
coming of the Antichrist by Richard
Gentry.
So, I don't exactly know like all the
details of the Anglo-Saxons, but I just
think it's interesting that it's it's
biblical. It has to do with something to
do with Antichrist. But you found out
that it meant dagger, right? Sort of.
Yeah, that's what it said on the one I
looked up. I just thought it's
interesting. Yeah. I could be wrong. I I
just got my stuff straight out of
Google. But it's interesting that even
where it says AI overview, they have a
star right next to it. Yeah, [laughter]
right.
But they'll star you everywhere.
So true.
Yeah. Star power.
Um
Damian. To me, that's just associated
with evil right there. But uh it says
Damian is given the name that means to
conquer.
So, we have a
a a winged lion that comes out of the
sea and with a dagger or a sword will
conquer. See what I mean? Like he's
telling a prophecy through the names of
these kids.
Yeah, enemies got that version. Wow. And
so this kid's name that is like X A E.
So I looked up what the parents say the
meaning is.
And I think this is the wife, Grimes's
or the not even the wife, girlfriend or
whatever,
explaining the meaning behind the name,
Grimes said X stands for the unknown
variable. So it means unknown.
Meanwhile, A E
is the Elvin spelling. So this is some
elf junk and I don't elves aren't no
Keebler elves making cookies. These are
demons.
It's a Elvin language spelling. It's the
Elvin spelling of A I. So now you got a
unknown A I, which is shorthand for
artificial intelligence,
but also the word love. You know, it's
like Come on, tell us what you really
mean. Don't give us like multiple things
here.
And then A-12, which is our favorite
aircraft. Hmm, something that's flying
in the sky.
Amber said the nickname [clears throat]
for that craft was the son of darkness.
Like one of the nicknames for the SR-71
cuz it's black.
It does say that is crazy right there.
But it does say Archangel. So if you put
this together, you got an unknown
uh
A I Archangel.
And then if you go to the next one, this
is what Eon said Elon Musk says.
Um
Yeah, you were right.
Oh, sorry.
Um
It Oh, the next one.
So Grimes and Musk seem to have
different ideas of This was on uh This
was on a regular like
I don't know, like today show or
something.
Grimes and Musk seem to have different
ideas on how to pronounce the name. It's
just X, like the letter X. And then A I,
like how you say the letter A I, Grimes
said. That's what she said. Then Musk,
meanwhile, told podcast Joe Rogan, I
mean it's just X, like the letter X. And
then the
A E is pronounced like is pronounced
ash.
And then A-12, A-12 is my contribution.
So she said it was like a love song, her
favorite song or something. So now look
what he's saying it means.
It's a it's an unknown
angel Archangel from the ashes or who
will become ashes.
This is Lucifer, man. When you read
I think it's Isaiah or Ezekiel. I don't
know why I always get those two mixed
up, but
there's a whole prophecy about the
the fate of Satan
and it says that you were in the Garden
of Eden and you were perfect in all your
ways until iniquity was found in you and
I will lay you before kings and I will
bring a fire from the midst of thee and
and you will become ashes on the face of
the earth and be no more.
That's the fate of Satan and now you
have this name that means a
unknown Archangel that's
and
[clears throat]
you got ashes.
So it's like either it's rising out of
the ashes or he's going to become ashes
or he's
I just I don't think that's a
coincidence, man. Mhm. No.
Too many coincidences for it to be a
coincidence. I know. Then azure means
sky blue, which I don't know, maybe you
can say Elon loves the sky, he's always
shooting stuff up in the sky, but Yeah.
Fire com- coming down from heaven.
Strider
means it's a German surname for a a
soldier. So again, we got this,
you know, coming to conquer soldier, a
nickname for someone who's aggressive.
Uh a strider comes from the words stride
or it can also mean a noun of a person
who walks or travels on foot. I think
it's more like this aggressive soldier
that's going to conquer with the sword
that represents Babylon that's coming
out of the sea.
And um
so this name is Exa Darka Siderael and
Exa
is a feminine name of American origin
that means adorned. Okay, this is
another one you're going to put
together.
So Exa means adorned.
And dark, because her middle name is
dark. I guess it's a her.
We know what dark means, no light. So
it's it's a adorned dark
star.
Because this word means
uh relating or to involving stars or
constellations. So if a star represents
an angel and it's a dark angel that is
adorned, we know that Lucifer was has
every precious stone with his was his
covering.
Mhm.
I mean, is this a stretch? No.
[laughter]
Jesus. It literally means an adorned
dark angel. Mhm.
And then he has this other kid named
Techno
uh Machinaeus or
Mechanicus or whatever it is.
Mechanicus. Mechanicus. And it just
means machine-like, which I just think
is crazy.
Yeah, name your son a terminator,
basically. Mhm.
Yes, where is John Connor when we need
him? I know, JC, come on.
Yeah, I thought that was weird looking
into all this stuff cuz I when I was
looking into this, just a a random like
news clip about A I popped up last year
and I click on it and it's talking about
how it's taking over in China, you know,
and everything in A everything is like
super these cameras that can scan your
well-being and your personality and how
you're feeling and all these different
things they can do. And I'm looking at
the corner when the guy is watching from
like this headquarters where you can see
all the camera screens, you know, of
people walking down the streets and it
had the name Skynet.
Oh, right there, dude. I was like,
Skynet? I was like, wait, wasn't that
Terminator? And I started freaking out.
I was like, let me look. Let me look.
Sure enough, Skynet was So again,
predictive programming.
Yeah. So they they they put it out
there. The demons have their plan. They
have their Skynet. Think about that.
Yeah. There's a [snorts] firmament above
us, but now they have a net or a web and
the world wide web
Yeah. trapping us with their Skynet from
above.
Wow. Dark.
Darkness. But yeah, that that um
lawlessness aspect with all of this,
what I was talking about at the
beginning, one of the things that the
demons taught mankind, obviously, was
lawlessness
um according to the Book of Enoch. I
just put it in number form so you can
see. I mean, godlessness and that's what
those demons were saying, don't worry
about any other god doing anything to
basically keep you in line. You can just
do whatever you want. Uh but they were
teaching all these different things. One
of them even being abortion. Talk about
in the Book of Enoch. They taught them
how to smite the infants in the womb.
And I'm like, that sounds like abortion
because it is. They even taught them the
mixing of roots to make birth control so
that the women could keep their figures.
Yeah, reducing the populations, you
know, things like that.
Very, very lawless. Um and there was
something that's related to that name
ash when I looked it up.
What did you find on that?
the uh deity L
that I I looked up was called A I. So
you have that A I aspect as well. What?
know much about that. So I don't want to
talk about it cuz I don't know a whole
lot about it, but somebody sent me
something and it said, look into this.
And I did and I was like, hmm, the
Canaanite deity
sometimes known as A I.
Where was mine? I thought I had another
slide in here. I guess I don't. With the
Messiah when he returns,
his quote, what he's going to say,
and it is it's powerful. Depart from me,
those of you who practice lawlessness.
Lawlessness.
And that is what they're trying to usher
in. To get do as thou wilt to be the
whole of the law. And when you look up
that word lawlessness, it means utter
disregard for God's law. And I don't
know about you guys, but I was raised
being told that don't worry about the
law stuff. That's all
Yep.
ancient, done away with, don't even
worry about it. And now I'm I'm learning
about it and looking into it and trying
not to be lawless and I'm going, man,
this is some good stuff in here. This is
some take care of your parents when
they're older. Love your neighbor. You
know, I'm just saying like there's so
many good things and and it's like no,
utterly disregard it and if you don't,
you're doing away with the sacrifice.
And I think a lot of that is lawlessness
being ushered in.
Um
And man, these names, that was crazy.
I'm glad you did that with those names.
I would have I knew there was something
there. I just never looked into it, but
getting back to that do as thou wilt. A
E
Eon of horse stuff. I mean, it's that's
what they want. They want you guys to
do as thou wilt. Make that be the whole
of the law.
Well, man. Sad sad.
Did you Was that the last slide you had?
Yeah, that was the last one. You can
take that down now. Yeah, I just I just
thought it's important for people to
see. They want us to focus and glory in
the stars. They want us to be lawless
and they want us to
hear those words, depart from me, and
then it apply to us and
the Father
he wants us to be saved. He sent us his
son as an example
and the world has their worldly examples
and got to stop follow the worldly
examples and follow in the footsteps of
the Messiah.
What's interesting is
you know,
it's it's amazing how many I would say
the Christians
voted for Trump and they trusted they
trust him. They look to him like he's
going to make good change and all that
stuff.
And yet he's the one that's
Elon only Elon could do that, bring down
fire
Only he can make fire come down from
above. Do you not remember the prophets
of Baal? Yeah. [laughter] Oh, yeah. And
and Elon
pillar of fire Yeah, and Elon's like,
I'm going to I'm going to make There was
a time when Elon said, this A I stuff,
it's going to get out of hand and this
is we should be afraid of this." And now
he's like, "Come on, let's microchip
your brain and let's make AI."
Yeah. And he Dude, what are the chances
that Trump, the last president, the last
Trump,
is teaming up with this guy who
is is pushing the propaganda of infinite
space and space travel and colonating
Mars and bringing in artificial
intelligence, robots, and self-driving
cars. I mean, this is how every
dystopian movie plays out.
Yeah.
Yeah, and he talks about it like, "Well,
you're not going to have to work. You'll
have a fixed income." And it sounds
great to people that are like, "That'd
be nice to just have robots coming in
cooking my food and me have a fixed
income." It just sounds so good. It's
like, "Oh, that'd be nice."
Uh but I think with the whole
forcing us into our homes and not
working and doing things, increases
lawlessness. When you were looking at
the pandemic time periods, trafficking
and people going to different websites
and stuff went sky rocketed cuz they're
not working. They don't have that
purpose, that drive. They're just Here's
you a a check. Here's $500 or whatever.
They're you know, $5,000 here. Now, go
Stay locked down and but lawlessness
started increasing real bad at that
moment. People people when those checks
started coming in, they said,
"This pays me more than my job. Why
would I get a job?" Mhm. Yeah. I can't
even afford to get a job because I'm
making more money sitting at home. And
idle hands are the devil's playground.
That's not a scripture, but it is the
truth. Yeah. When you're not working,
you know, the Bible does say if you
don't work, you don't eat and and things
like that.
We are supposed to do things, not just
sit around and be tempted by everything.
I mean, especially if you're watching
TV,
you're scrolling around on the internet,
there's always going to be temptation.
There's always going to be
some ad for something you shouldn't be
looking at or just some debauchery
that's being glamorized.
And we're really just wasting time. We
are Yeah. We're living in the end times.
And if we're not in God's word, we're
not in prayer, then Satan's winning.
Mhm. That's the only defense we have
against him. We are weak. We are
pathetic in the sight of a angel. Now, a
lot of Christians don't like you talking
about Satan like he's powerful, but he
is. Let's be realistic. One angel
[clears throat] could slay thousands of
people.
And even Jesus
knew he had to depend on the word of God
to fight Satan.
And that's why it's the sword of the
spirit. And that's Satan's main
tactic is to distract. Keep us
distracted, keep you scrolling, keep you
playing addictive video games, keep you
intoxicated through drugs, alcohol,
terrible food that's destroying your
body, all these things. And he's
he's ready to come out on the scene as a
false Christ. And the worse and worse
the world gets, the more the stage is
being set up with these natural
disasters and
86 genders and age is just a preference
and all this stuff,
the world is primed and ready to say,
"We need change. We need to get back to
God because this world is going crazy."
And now you got a president that's
saying, "I'm going to make America pray
again."
Yeah. You can't force people to pray.
You can't force religion onto society.
It never works. God never forces himself
on any human, any humanity.
The greatest gift God ever gave was
freedom of choice. That's true love.
And so I I see things going towards this
far right swing where there's going to
be forced worship. And we see that in
Revelation. And I think it's going to be
kind of this coexist, you know, like
we're all the children of God and
if you don't believe that, then you're
the problem. You're a bigot. You need to
be locked up and
we just all need to, you know, go to
church every Sunday and check in. You
know, it's all going to be like uh
some kind of system like, "All right, I
I I went. I'm I'm checking in. I
worshiped the beast today."
scan my wrist. Beep.
[laughter]
All right.
The social credit scores and all this
stuff. Oh, you missed church. Your
social credit score dropped. You can't
take public transport today.
Yeah. Well, I couldn't go to work during
the um pandemic until they they got a
scanner and they scanned your forehead.
I'm like, beep, all right, you're good.
You can go in. I'm like, I'm glad I
don't have a barcode. That's the one
thing that
keeps us apart. But yeah, I You were
talking about praying in the end times
and stuff. And it it reminded me I was
as we're talking as I'm looking into the
AI, is there was a time where Israel
battled AI. Literally battled what was
called AI. And they were losing. It was
the one time where they they were
losing. They came back defeated. They
lost a few you know, a few dozen people.
And they're like, "What's going on? You
know, the father's usually taking out
these people for us. We don't have to to
do this." But the father revealed there
was a sin. Somebody had sinned. They had
disobeyed and taken treasure from I
think Jericho and kept it, buried it,
hid it. And when that person um Achor, I
think Achor was the name, was punished.
Is it Achan? Achan? Achan?
looked it up before we got on and it was
like Achan or Arcan or something. Yeah.
Achan or Arcan, yeah. And so he was
punished. He was um punished. And once
he was punished and they purified
themselves and they repented, then they
destroyed AI. And they didn't just
destroy them. They surrounded AI
on different sides. And whenever AI came
out and they saw Joshua and a few of
them,
um they Joshua and them, I think they
like ran off and act like they were
retreating. And so AI is prideful like,
"Oh, we're going to go get them." And
then they look back and their town is on
fire cuz Israel just
blazed their place, you know, set it on
fire. And then they're like, "Well, now
we're trapped." And then they got wiped
out. So AI lost. Could be prophetic
there. AI losing. They may get the upper
hand for a minute. They might be taken
over and think they're winning and have
us outnumbered. But once you purify
ourselves, we live we serve a living,
powerful, all powerful creator. And
their their powers of darkness are
nothing. They can't touch us once we get
with within that um actual realm, the
spirit realm, the Holy Spirit realm, not
the demonic realm that they want us to
get in with their X's and crossing over
and all that. Holy Spirit is powerful.
It's real. They don't want you to know
who you are, what you live on, and what
you're capable of when you have the Holy
Spirit. And so there's so many different
things you can do. And there's no limit
to our father's power. He made
everything. And he is our creator. We're
his inheritance. And so I'm blessed to
be that inheritance. And
I'm seeing some questions. Somebody
asked if we were in the little season.
I can't remember who it was that asked
that. And I wanted to answer that and
say we're in the long season.
[laughter]
It's the same goal. The goal is there's
a threat from above. That is what you're
going to be seeing in the news. They're
doing that with the aliens now. The
threats from above. Once the the rain
begins, once the return happens and
every eye sees the Messiah,
then we're going to have that 1,000
years of peace with enemies bound. Just
like there's enemies bound now. They're
going to be bound. Then they're going to
be let loose. And then there's a little
season. And the reason when you hear the
word little season and going out to
deceive the world, you think, "Oh my
goodness, that sounds like where we're
at now." We have the same goal right now
with these unclean spirits like frogs
going to the kings of the earth to
deceive them to that battle to gather
them together to battle in a place
called Armageddon. Guess what?
Armageddon is owned by the United
Nations. They're going to try to unite
the world powers to go there. And
they've already done a rehearsal. They
had a drill, Steadfast Defender, where
they had I I think it was like 90,000
troops, army tanks, and everything. Like
they were there to practice in case
there was a near peer threat. And so
they're practicing near and they did
this near Armageddon. So they're
practicing these things and getting us
geared up for this threat from above,
this alien threat, this extraterrestrial
threat. Even the movie Armageddon that
was in the '90s, late '90s, um you guys
probably remember that. Armageddon.
Where was the threat from? Up above. Who
saved us? Who was the savior? NASA. NASA
was our savior. They saved us.
They sent people who were digging down
deep into the earth, down into
uh shield. They Oh, they're they're
going to save us. These people from down
below the earth came up and got hired by
NASA and destroyed this asteroid. And
so yeah, the threats from above right
now with the uh little season, where is
the threat? The threat is the camp of
the saints. It's already there. And
people have been going every year to
keep the Feast of Tabernacles from every
nation. Otherwise, they won't get rain.
And so that hasn't been going on. And
we're getting rain.
And so yeah, there's They're they're
similar.
Little Armageddon, Gog Magog, similar
purpose. Attack the Most High and his
people. And so, you know, when there's a
resurrection and we're gathered by
angels and we're up there, who knows? We
might be up there. We might be a part of
that threat. Wouldn't that be cool? You
know? They're like, "There's the threat
right there." I do believe that's why we
have a space force all of a sudden, you
know? And that was under Trump, too,
which is ironic. That Trump brought in
the Space Force. So now we're not just
protecting the land, the sea, and the
air, but now we're building weapons
pointed towards the heavens
and creating propaganda that makes it
look like that they have a justifiable
reason to do it. They because there's an
asteroid that's coming so close to
earth. And and because there's aliens,
you know? And so the people are going to
say, "Yeah, we need we need these big
weapons to point towards the heavens."
And they're just preparing to fight
Christ when he comes.
We need Elon to save us cuz this threat
is huge. I mean, it's a big threat, you
know? It's going to wipe out all the
wickedness.
[laughter]
We need Elon. Only Elon could do this.
Fire from above, yeah. He's got I I just
watch. I'll say this on the air.
Probably going to be a Tony Stark figure
even more so really soon with his heroic
Something's going to happen, I feel
like. Some sort of threat. And they're
going to send in old Elon, you know,
he's right there chain of command and
president's buddy-buddy with him. He can
be on the phone with him. Yeah, we need
you Elon.
We got this threat over here.
[laughter]
Can you send up maybe you could use
Starlink? I don't know. This could be
huge.
[laughter]
You got to laugh at man. It's like
that's all you can do and you're just
watching prophecy roll out.
Their schemes.
Yeah,
yeah, Maga Maga is a level of devil
worship. Somebody said that in the
comments. Maga. I saw that recently. I
wonder.
The grand Maga's, yeah. They're
like the highest high priest.
Okay. They have their priests. They have
their sacrifices. They mimic the most
high's system. They want to be like him.
They have their own appointed times.
Their own holy days. Their high holy
days. You guys talked about Halloween. I
learned stuff watching you guys talk
about that. I'm like, I never thought of
that. Their high their holy day, you
know, hallowed. He hallowed you know,
certain things and they're like, they're
hallowed.
Creepy.
We grew up in Babylon.
Didn't know it.
Wow, man.
Anybody got any closing thoughts? You
got anything?
No. I I'm shocked to hear what I did,
but at the same time it makes sense. It
doesn't
literally I guess shock me to death like
I kind of expected it. I I know that
invent um
inventors
on this earth are
usually getting supernatural help from
the demon
world
to do so. To move us toward the agenda
of the occult
new world order and so on.
And the antichrist movement
uh to move and progress us into the
plans they have for us.
Yeah. Um
and so I mean it all lines up and it
almost seems like he's trying to breed
the new Lucifer with all of his
children.
Right. But
yeah.
I expected as much.
Yeah.
Well, bro, thank you so much for
covering this on our show, man. It was
only like 30 minutes on yours, but I
think we did an hour and a half, but it
was awesome getting to just kind of
discuss and dive deeper in some of these
things. So, you know, if people want the
short format, the shareable one, they
can share yours. It was nice and edited.
They want to hear the long
deep dive that we did, they can watch it
here. But if you guys don't know about
Founded Earth Brothers, that's what
Josh's channel is. Check it out. It's
got some amazing content on there. You
you'll be able to scroll and and
binge-watch for days, but you're going
to binge-watch something that's actually
good and educational and biblical and
not a bunch of Netflix garbage. So, go
check out their stuff. And thank you so
much for being on here, man. It was I I
really appreciate you sharing what you
did. And I hope that people here were
blessed.
Yeah.
I was blessed to be on here and thanks
for reaching out to us. We need to unite
in these last days. We need so many
people coming together to
form these relationships where they're
not fighting over things they don't
agree on. Like we need to unite. They
are united. They're trying to keep us
divided left, right, north, south,
black, white, straight, whatever
whatever [laughter] they can use to
divide us. They're like, let's just
section them all up so they can't work
together cuz they know if we were to
come together and pray to our creator
and there's power in that. So, unite
with the other believers.
Stay humble.
Amen. Very true.
Well, thank you, bro, and we'll
stick on there. We'll we'll say
something to you afterwards. We're going
to sign off here.
[clears throat]
Thank you guys for joining this
conversation. I hope it was a blessing
to you. If it was, click the thumbs up.
If you're new to this channel, click the
subscribe. We want to build a community
here of people who are like-minded and
where we can even discuss things and you
know, even debate things or whatever,
but we want to find the truth. We're all
in this journey together. We are we're
all in this deception where the dragon
is deceiving the entire world. And so,
this channel is about finding the truth,
talking about it candidly, talking about
things that the church doesn't want to
talk about, tough topics.
If you really enjoy this type of
content, you can you can support this
ministry because we stepped out in faith
about 4 months ago. We're doing this
all just trusting in God that he's going
to provide. And so, if you feel led to
give, we
can't thank you enough for that. You can
do so through Cash App, through Venmo,
through Zelle. We also have some merch.
If you want to go and go to
candidtruth.org,
there's a button there you can click to
see our store and there's a lot of cool
t-shirts there. We actually get probably
$5 from each of those sales.
And so, we we design these shirts and
they're really cool way to
just reach out to people with scripture
or like a cool message like it's cool to
use your brain because in this world of
propaganda, there's so much propaganda
about it's cool to be dumb. Like Beavis
and Butt-Head. It's not cool to be smart
because you'll be shoved in the locker,
right? And that's all just propaganda.
It's cool and sexy to be smart and we
should all be striving to know the
truth. Satan wants us to stay deceived.
And we love you guys. We thank you for
being here. We can't do this without you
guys and we'll see you next time. Candid
Truth. Thank you.